let me ask the all-important question uh
do you know how much Atlas can curl
[Laughter]
have you
I mean you know this for us humans
that's really one of the most
fundamental questions you can ask
another human being
bench it probably can't curl as much as
we can yet but a metric that I think is
interesting is um you know another way
of looking at that strength
is you know the box jump so if how high
of a box can you jump onto question and
uh Alice I don't know the exact height
it was probably a meter high or
something like that it was a pretty
pretty tall jump that Atlas was able to
manage when we last tried to do this and
and I have video of uh my chief
technical officer doing the same jump
and he really struggled you know the
human but the human getting all the way
on top of this box but then you know
Atlas was able to do it
um we're now thinking about the next
generation of Atlas and we're probably
going to be in the realm of a person
can't do it you know with this with the
Next Generation the robots the actuators
are going to get stronger where there
really is the case that at least some of
these joints some of these motions will
be stronger and to understand how high
it can jump you probably had to do quite
a bit of testing oh yeah and there's
lots of videos of it trying and failing
and that's you know that's all you know
we don't always release those those
videos but they're a lot of fun to look
at
uh so we'll talk a little bit about that
uh but if can you talk to the jumping
because you talked about the walking it
took a long time many many years to get
the walking to be natural but there's
also really natural looking
uh robust resilient jumping how hard is
it to do the jumping well again this
stuff has really evolved rapidly in the
last few years you know the first time
we did a somersault
um you know there's a lot of kind of
manual iteration
what is the trajectory you know how hard
do you throw it in fact in these early
days uh I actually would when I'd see
early experiments that the team was
doing I might make suggestions about how
to change the technique again kind of
borrowing from my own intuition about
how backflips work
um
but frankly they don't need that anymore
so in the early days you had to iterate
kind of in almost a manual way trying to
change these trajectories of the arms or
the legs to try to get you know a
successful backflip to happen
but more recently we're running
these model predictive uh control
techniques where we're able to the robot
essentially can think in advance for the
next second or two about how its motion
is going to transpire and you can you
know solve for optimal trajectories to
get from A to B so this is happening in
a much more natural way and we're really
seeing an acceleration happen in the
development of these behaviors again
partly due to these
optimization techniques sometimes
learning techniques
so it's there's it's hard in that
there's a lot of mathematics and behind
it but we're figuring that out so you
can do model predictive control for
uh I mean I don't even understand what
that looks like when the entire robot is
in the air flying and doing a backflip
yeah I mean but but that's the cool part
right so you know yeah you know the
physics we we can calculate physics
pretty well using you know Newton's laws
about how it's going to evolve over time
and the road you know this this the sick
trick which was a front somersault with
a half twist is a good example right
you saw the robot on various versions of
that trick I've seen it land in
different configurations and it still
manages to stabilize itself and so you
know what this model predictive control
means is again the in real time the
robot is projecting ahead you know a
second into the future and sort of
exploring options and if I if I move my
arm a little bit more this way how is
that going to affect the outcome and so
it can do these calculations many of
them you know uh and and basically solve
for you know given where I am now maybe
I took off a little bit screwy from how
I had planned I can adjust so you're
adjusting in there just on the fly so
the the model predictive control lets
you adjust on the Fly
and of course I think this is what you
know people adapt as well we when when
we do it even a gymnastics trick we try
to set it up so it's as close to the
same every time but we figured out how
to do some adjustment on the Fly and now
we're starting to figure out that the
robots can do this adjustment on the fly
as well using these techniques in the
air
and so I mean it just feels from a
robotics perspective just surreal well
that's sort of the you talked about
under actuated right so when you're in
the air there's something there's some
things you can't change right you can't
change the momentum while it's in the
air because you can't apply an external
force or Torque and so the momentum
isn't going to change so how do you work
within the constraint of that fixed
momentum to still get from A to B where
you want to be that's really unfortunate
you're in the air I mean you become a
drone for a brief moment of time no
you're not even a drone because you
can't can't ever you can't hover you're
gonna you're gonna impact soon be ready
yeah are you considered like a hover
type thing or no no it's too much weight
I mean it's just it's just incredible uh
and just even to have the guts to try
backflip with such a large body
that's wild what like uh we definitely
broke a few robots trying but that's
where the build it break it fix it you
know uh strategy comes in and you gotta
be willing to break and what ends up
happening is you end up by breaking the
robot repeatedly you find the weak
points and then you end up redesigning
it so it doesn't break so easily next
time you know through the breaking
process you learn a lot like a lot of
lessons and you keep improving not just
how to make the backflip work but
everything and how to build the machine
better yeah yeah
I mean is there something about just the
guts that
come up with an idea of saying you know
what let's try to make it to a backflip
well I think the courage to do a
backflip in the first place and and to
not worry too much about the ridicule of
somebody saying why the heck are you
doing backflips with robots because a
lot of people have asked that you know
why why why are you doing this why go to
the moon in this decade and do the other
things JFK
not because it's easy because it's hard
yeah exactly
don't ask questions